5 26 on your wednesday morning time for  our periodic junior traffic buddy lesson  in reporting traffic signal issues  viewer shari wrote in hey during  afternoon rush hour traffic backs up  onto the westbound southern 215 beltway  exit at durango and sunset she says it  causes a very dangerous situation well i  suggest that you and anyone who has ever  sent in intersection specific emails  that you visit the regional  transportation commission's website  called seeing orange nv.com  you go there there are email addresses  and a phone number where your call will  be answered by a real person between the  hours of 5 a.m to 11 p.m monday through  friday 7am to 8pm weekends the number  702-901-8400  it is in the online version of this  along with all our stories when you go  to r8newsnow.com website click traffic  then driving you crazy thanks for  writing in sherry buckle up drive  carefully please put on the phone  something's driving you crazy email me  traffic 8 8newsnow.com